was ist das zwischen haftbefehl und
klicks um hass oder liebe oder hass
liebe auf jeden fall gibt es immer eine
menge zündstoff wenn haft für felix um
kommt und es ist wieder soweit und wir
reden über sein neuestes werk blog
platin und unter anderem auch den titel
ja bloß wissen wer der babo ist klingt
irgendwie so ein bisschen wie so ein
baukasten für kinder und ansonsten man
versteht auch wirklich kaum was im text
ich habe den verdacht er haftbefehl ist
ein total ausgefuchster aktionskünstler
der uns jahrelang verarscht hat
inklusive julians blog darüber wenn er
reden und natürlich über eure fragen die
ihr am besten in den kommentaren posten
oder noch besser als video antwort auf
dieses video hochladen dann den info
text lesen und dann kann eigentlich
nichts mehr schief gehen oder doch auf
jeden fall bis dann bleibt dran